כן,
בגיל המצלמה שהיום
היום
ה
בחודש ינואר
ראיון
עם
חוט כדר
ג'ייקוב לשעבר אני פנג לוי
פרויקט עומדות ישראל
אוקיי.
בוקר טוב.
בוקר יותר
השאלה הראשונה. עוד שנייה אחת אני מטפס על זה.
כן,
השאלה הראשונה
שאת מכירה את עצמך
דורות אחורה
כמה הכי רחוק
מאחד הצדדים את יודעת, לספר על השורשים.
זה
מצד האמא שלי. זה
יוציא
מה שהיה אז רוסיה והיום זה אוקראינה
כאב.
אני יודעת
שזה
מעט
על השמשה שלי
שהגיע ארצה ב
מכיב.
שמו היה
רם יו שהוא אדון ביקור.
הוא היה מ
על הנייר ממיקי מרחובות וקנה אדמה ברחובות.
אבל נפטר בגיל
כשעוד היה ב
יפו בנוה צדק,
הוא היה לו בית בנאום
הוא הגיע, ובצדק,
קנה אדמה ברחוב. את
זה נמצא בכתובים הסיפור
אז
אז אבל אני
זה לא מה שאני
זה אבא שלי, אימא שלי
שמת
בעצם לפני שאמא שלי נולדה ולכן כלול נחמה בל אפשר
ממה שאני נפטרה. היא נולדה ב
כן,
שנייה אחת בגללך.
האנשים שאני
יודעת עליהם בדיוק. אז
אז כמובן, אני הכרתי את הסבתא שלי,
דון ביקוב
גוש י'
בבית כי בלי ש
כי היא מתה רק ב
רגע,
היא גדלה. אני גדלתי
עם שפ.
ואני ידעתי מהשיפורים
מכיוון שהשבת תתעלם ממנה בגיל מאוד צעיר.
אמא שלי אמא שלי,
מי שגר בבית כל השנים ברחובות
היה מי שהיה יודעת מצד
זה מייצג את הסבתא שלי, רב יענק'ל קיפניס
שהוא
ואשתו היו בבית, היא היתה אלמנה עם שני ילדים והם היו בבית עוד הייתי שומע את הסיפורים
ואמא שלי על ביאנקה ויש תמונות עם זה הקטן גדול איש ספר.
היו הרבה דברים.
זה מה שאני יודעת
מי
שמיעה.
ומצד שאבא שלי אבא שלי היה עם מדאם דעה.
באמת ששתי.
אני הכרתי את
סבא וסבתא שוני היטב, כי אנחנו נוסעים לאנגליה.
גם
כשהייתי ילדה קטנה
והייתי השלם של השבת בסבתא שלי.
חשבת שאני,
שירה ג'יקובס
היתה ירידת
אנגליה
מעל
זה במזרח אנגליה, משם הגיעו
היהודים המזרחים. אבל עכשיו יש לי כבר נולדה. והסבא שלי
הגיע לאנגליה בגיל שתים.
ואז
דני יודע את
זה.
האם אנדי גם
אני הייתי רואה אותם? היו
אנשים
שומרי דה.
לא הופנה טיקו, אבל לא לכל בית כנסת שאמרו כשר
אומרים את זה
כשאנחנו מדברים על משפחה. אז
יש
במקרה רגיש למען החקר ההיסטוריה
את שם משפחתה של סבתך. וניכנס
כשהבנתי. אה,
כן,
לא שמעתי. אמא שלי. זה ג'ייקוב.
שבת. כאילו שלך
שמעתי מישהו
מנישואיה. היתה דון בייקון
בצד של
רגע זה שנים השני.
אז
בוא נדבר רגע רק לצד אחד
אחר בצד אחד
ואז בנוה
הצד של אמא. שנתחיל? בצד שלי, למשל,
שאלה בעצם שורשים הרבה עכשיו, אך
בישראל ערוכים עמוד מהודרת, ישראלי עוד
שהשורשים שלהם, אבל איפה מתחילים ברוסיה?
בכאב. כן, מכיר.
כן,
אני
עכשיו
כן, אני יודעת על המשפחה,
אבל רק משמיעה
מהשיפורים שלי. אמא שלי
היתה משפחה,
עמידה
בורגנית.
יש לי תמונות שהיו הדודות באות אחרי ש
עכשיו תחליט על מנה מהסבא שלי ידון במקורו
המשפחה הייתה נגיעה. הן עד המהפכה הרוסית
עד אלף תשע מאות ו.
אז
תשמע את זה. אבל בעצם במלחמה, אם כבר לא בא עד
אבל הם היו באים. ויש לי המון
המון תמונות של
כבירים בשמלות תבת בכובעים. וזה,
והנה אתה. נתתי לך את הכלי. היה
זה בא מהבית של
זה?
זה בית,
יש לי הרבה כלי כסף, אני לא רואה פה זה ככה.
כתוב פה
זה כל מיני כנסת
כסף
שהגיעו נר משפחת דומיניקה, ויש לי המון
מאז.
הפעם מודים בגובה אל
מקיר.
אז עכשיו אני יודעת עליו. תראה,
הוא השיפור המשפחתי הוא
שהוא כבר ידעת תרופתית והיו הולכים לאופרה
והשיפורים
ושיום אחד ונסעה ברכבת
ופגשתי
אחד העם. ואולי פולקלור משפחתי,
וכל
אחד היה מאוד מאוד השפיע עליו. ואז התארגנה
קבוצה שנקראת מנוחה ונחלה
שלו, שהיה אחת לא,
זה לא זה. פוטרתי. יוני
היו שם אולי שני מ
איש אבל זה
בכתובים היסטוריים
והם החליטו
להקים
מושבה. שאלות לא היה ברור
אם אתה אולי יודע וב וכ
וכאן הוא עכשיו
הזיכרון שלי ושם אותו פחות טוב,
זה
הם הלכו למשך שלהן אוהב שיושב של רחובות עכשיו היה הכפר.
שכחתי את השם עכשיו
ורצו לקנות את האדמה שלו. חולש על בדורה.
קחו אחר מדור אווירי מחיר בדוגמה
והשיפור
שהשף של מחיר מדורן אמר
אתה לא קונים חלק אתם קונים את כל אשר אלף דונם
לא היה להם כסף ליותר טוב.
השפענו הישווה שלי, שהיה איש מי
שהיה בניווט שניק עם מה שאני יודע בנוה צדק
ושאלו אתם רוצה להצטרף הוא לא היה מה?
האידיאלים האלה שרצים לבנות מושבה
והוא אמר כן, הוא קנה אלף דונם
ואף פעם ואמר אני יהיה
אבנרי בית
לגור שם
כבר היו כבר היו שתי הבנות,
אבל הוא
לא הייתה אמא שלי עוד לא נולדו
והוא והוא מדלקת ריאות. אז מי אם לא
הוא היה עוד בנוה צדק
הבית הוא חי כבר
התחילו לבנות הביתה והוא לא הוא לא זכה לעבור שם
ושמעתי שהתעלמנו. אתה עולה בת
שלוש?
לא. אז מה? את הארץ.
אז
אם רק אם בתחת
אלמן עם ילדה לא
היו שנייה.
אנחנו אמא שלי תמיד אמרה לי,
אני נכנסת כל פריט
שהיא נולדה
שישה חודשים אחרי שאבא שלה מת,
אבל קראו לה נחמה.
וכשאנחנו הולכים לבית הקברות הישן ברחובות, אנחנו רואים
כשאמא שלי
מתה,
נולדה אחרי שעשה בשנים האלה שידי היתה נחמה,
חשבתי שהיא לא רצתה לחזור לרוסיה.
אני שרון נאמנה לרעיון
הציוני כביכול של
קן
בגילאי שתי הבנות ברחובות, בבית שעומד עכשיו מוזיאון לא במקום
כמו זעום.
הכל
רק מתוך הן לא ואין קשב, אמרה. אבל
חשוב מזה, מוזיאון כביכול
בבית,
מאוד מהבתים הישנים.
וכך
וככה
וככה נשארו וכל פעם היו באים עם
הדודים והדודות הכבירים האלה והם מטפלים,
ואני יודעת שהדוד או שלי יש שטר שמי לאנסקי
נעשה כמה פעמים לראש עיר. אמא שלי
עד המהפכה. אמא שלי לא מרשה.
אז בוא נספר עכשיו על האס מלאנס, כי על
זה
או מה ששלי
לשיפורים סוגריים מאוד גדולות.
יש
לי שטר שמילה,
משפחת דון בקוב
ומשפחת
משה סמילנסקי
לשתות. שילה,
איפה יש לנו שלא
היו מאוד מעוניינים.
אני הכרתי את את שצ'ילה,
אבל
כל המושבה ידע. חוץ מהילדים כזה לא דיברו
שמו שמנהל
רומן
עם משטרת הסתר בארון ג'ייקוב
הוא
מישהי, אולי בת.
הוא היה אב לשלושה ילדים.
זה הסיפור ידוע וזה אני. יש לי פה דוקטורנטים שפשוט
לא להאמין שהוא כותב לה מכתבים. אסתר כי עבדתי עם
לו ז ז
זה סיפור בפני עצמו.
ואז
והיא חיכתה נו,
האיש טוד שלה נפטרה ב
ואז הם התחתנו.
דודתי הייתה בת חמישים
בלי עניינים.
יש שליטה על מלחמה, שחיקה תגיע והם לא הם היו כל הזמן כי הם היו מבלים יחד.
ידועה בזה אז
כן יכול
כן,
קיבלו את זה רחוב. את יודעת מה?
כולם היו נשים יחד בחולשה, ערבויות
קודם, כמו
כן, אני הכרתי אני כאן אם קראתי לדוד משה ותני שהיה דוד שלי
הוא היה חלק מהמו מ
אני גדלתי בירושלים
רגע, אנחנו נזכיר את באיזו שנה את נולדת? אחר כך נגיע
אז אני נולדתי ב
תגיד
בסופו
ונולדתי בירושלים
בגדול
כל יום אותי אמרה בירושלים
אני רוצה להגיע עכשיו
בשנייה
עכשיו
זה הצד
ההורים של
אבא בוא, אני רוצה הורים שנשארים עם האמא לך אנגליה
עכשיו להורים שלה
היה משפחת ג'יקובס
אז
אוקיי,
מאיפה הם מגיעים? זאת אומרת, אנחנו יודעים יהודים באנגליה
היו היה
כולל פולנים
מפולין
אנא, אני אף פעם לא התעסקתי בזה אבל יש לי בן של בן דוד שמתעסק בזה אנגלי
ששמו ג'ק גם שתי וג'ק ודוני בקשר איתו
הוא משפחתו משפחות או לא גדול.
הוא נסע ל פולניה
למצוא את העיירה שממנה באה שאבא שלי אבל אני לא כל כך התעניינתי כן, גם את השקר הזה.
השבוע שלי הגיע בגיל שתים עשרה.
יהל
איצ'י מדבר על אבל במזרח ועיר נמל.
אחר כך הם עברו למנצ'סטר כן,
כי
המשפחה של אשתו הסכמתי כששתי לרמן שתזייפי
והיה
הקימו חברה מאוד גדול
בזמנו,
כשאני הייתי נוסעת לאנגליה בתור ילדה קטנה
הם גרו בבית גדול מאוד.
כאלה בורגנים.
עם מי
כן?
כן ראיתי עם שלוש קומות בצ'יק המהיר. זה נקרא במנצ'סטר.
השכונה הזו שלא היו הרבה יהודים.
היה להם
טקסטיל עם
סדינים ומגבות, והיה להם
אם היו
כמה בני דודים. היו זו חברה משפחתית כזאת.
כמה בני דודים היו בדרום אפריקה, וכמה מנשוא לארגנטינה. נראה שיהודים אמורים.
אני עוד פגשתי.
כשהייתי אולי בת,
בני דודים של אבא שלי שהגיעו מארגנטינה, היו כולם הם ענייני שדנים. מגבות,
טקסטיל, אם
כן,
אנחנו ממש עשירים על
עכשיו.
אז זה הכל. אני ראיתי נוסעת לחופשה, והייתי ממשלתם גרו בבית גדול,
הייתה
מבשלת עליונות ועוזרת
והילדים
לאבא שלי היו שבעה. הם היו שבעה אחים. משפחה גדולה.
כן,
הם כולם
הלכו למזל עם למען ששתי גריימס. כל שזה היה בית ספר
עירוני
שעד היום הוא יוצא מן הכלל, מימן שהשתגעו למשהו.
הבני דודים שלי כולם הלכו לאוגי.
לא מפני שהם היו עשירים בימים אלה. כי העיניים חינוך טוב.
דיון בזה עד היום. זה ידוע שדרך
לדברי
מי
היו פעם להיות ופעם ירידות בזמן משנת
משבר כלכלי היו נפילות. עוד מכרו את הביתה ונועל ואמרו למאי קטן
ואחר כך שוב פעם מתרומם הוא העסקנות.
אני ממש מקווה.
כן,
אבל תמיד כשאני
הייתי קטנה, הפעם האחרונה שראיתי את
סבא וסבתא של
אז הם נפטרו,
ישנו להונגריה.
אז שהם
ישמרו שמה
היינו אוכלים
ביום שישי מברכות,
מה שלא היה אצלנו
כן
שאמרו ללון
ככה
יוני האוכל בית כנסת בבוקר עם השידור,
השאלה באחד מהצדדים באופן כללי, שאלה
יש
איזשהו סיפור של
פוגרום, אנטישמיות, משהו התמודדות במשפחה אחת, אחת השאלות
ומאפשר
מה זה הדבר הזה?
יש שלנו
מה שאני אומר
כן. כדי בצד של בצ'ק של אבא שלי. בוודאי. לא
כן,
אבל האנגלי.
אבל בית.
אני הרבה פעמים
עושה חשבון
שאם הסבא שלי הגיע האלה ב
שאולי כתוצאה מ הפורומים של
עם זה היום.
כי אולי אם הוא הולם על מידע
זה הכל מן.
מכיוון שהוא עומד בנישואי שבע.
פה יש איזה לקונה נורא גדולה.
אף אחד לא
לא את לא היו,
לא ייתן לנו
אף פעם לא.
אני יודעת שהיא התכתבו
עד המהפכה, אבל אחר כך אני גדלתי. הייתי שומעת את זה, קצת שיפורים, אבל
לא יסתכלו אחורה אף פעם לא באירוע. אפילו בזמן השואה. את המשפחה הגדולה.
יש לי תמונות של כל
בתש,
התחתנו
דון. במקום הם יושבים ו בתשע
רק חיים.
כן,
את תמיד
העניין של שורשים לא היה קיים.
אימא שלי
אישה מאוד אינטליגנטית, קוראת המון,
אף פעם לא אמרה מה קרה
גם לו, גם
מה קרה לה,
למשפחה, אפילו בשואה
לא
נגמר. היתה מהפכה.
הקשר מתאפק. לא דיברו בטלפון
ברחובות.
זה
חי.
חי, הוא חננו.
עכשיו בואו נחזור לג'יפ כוס באנגליה, כי היו
ועכשיו אביך מאתיים נולד.
אבי נולד ב
גם כמו אימא שלי
מיולי ממני.
כן,
זה
מה,
עד שהוא מתגייס לצבא. אז הוא למד. דוג אמר אתה בזמן ששתי גולם השכול, ואחר כך הלך לי
לאוניברסיטת
מנצ'סטר, מלמד כימיה והוציא תואר ראשון, בטוח שני,
ושם הוא פגש את בית שהוא הכיר אותו במודעת. ראית פעם והתמנה אמרת של
הכימיה כשאבא שלי
עוד ש
אמרתי אוי, אך אם היית
כל כך הרבה יהודים היו בתחום הכימיה.
גם אבא שלי אבא שלהם.
ולכן אני לא מוכן בעצמן.
אבל אבל אבא שלי לא עושה
בזה אחר כך.
בגלל
וב
ב.
בן כמה הוא היה בן שמונה
אחרי שהוא גמרתם תואר שני
הוא התגייס לצבא,
בילה
שלוש שנים ב
בשום
בחפירות ב שהוא היה אז לא היה קטין.
אז יש לי חומרים, אבל
ובערך כמה מפרש ועשוי את
הג'וש בטליאן מבט עליונה
בגדודים.
אז הוא התנדב לדיונים והיה קצין
ובו ילדי המלך.
דוד קליי המלך. הוא היה
כן,
השנה שמונה.
עכשיו
כתוב את זה. אני לא אני הייתי בא. מיכה את זה.
אוהב אותי זה להיות
שכחתי באיזה מהם,
אז אני יודעת, אבל שלך הזה
מעניין.
אז הוא היה קטן אחרי שלוש שנים בצבא כחייל רגיל.
בשר.
והוא כבר לא ילד? לא, לא ילד ומשקיעים
כי יש לו מרים איזה הפסיקה טרף לגדודים העבריים.
אנחנו בטח צעד במצעד המפורסם הזה בלונדון.
אני לא יכולה. לא, אני אגיד לך את היקף מה המשטרה שלו.
והוא היה שלי שם. מרגולין, אתה יודע מי זה מר גולד?
עכשיו מרגו להם
שבא מאוסטרליה, קולונל לחתיך הזה
היה ממונקו רחוב אותי.
נכון.
והוא
כן, הוא. הוא היה אחד לאוסטרה יעלות מאיזה סיבות גם
והוא לפי מה שאנחנו מבינים
אם
אני הרחק לספר לך למה אמא שלי למדה מוסיקה בגרמניה
ושתי הדודות היא למדה פסיכולוגיה ובארי עשתה בתיכון הפסיכולוגיה
שתי בנות מכובה שמשהו ללמוד
והם
וניגנו בבית. היה פסנתר בבית ברחובות.
ותמיד מפליא אותי כי אמא שלי למדה
פסנתר אני כן,
ו
מארגונים לקח את אבא שלי. הוא אמר, יש פה איזה קונצרט או אמא שהייתה מנגנת והיה
לו וככה משה שידוך. בקיצור,
הוא ידע שיש שם שתי בנות יפות,
תכולות עיניים, והיא והביא את אבא שלי שהיה כקטין
ואחר כך הם.
אז מרגולין בעצם אחראי, השתכן,
אחראי להיווצרות, איך
כן,
כשהוא היה שד חם. זה ברור שכן.
גם המשפחה שלי, קירק מרגולין, עוד מלפני
ננסי שמשהו, בטח במפגש מינימום. אז מדברים ואומרים אם האמא שלי שיפרה את
אמא שלי, לא ידעו אנגלית,
ידעה עברית וגרמנית. דוגמאות דיברה גרמנית
שמונה שנים בגרמניה
מ
נתקע במלחמה על
עשרים
ועשרים. היא חזרה בבקשה את אבא שלי,
אז ילמדו. אחר כך למדה אנגלית טובה מאוד.
הם דיברו ביניהם אנגלית.
רגע
השנייה
אמא שלה איפה? איפה היה העניין הזה של הקונצרט?
אמא שלי חזרה ב
כמעט שבע שנים בברלין כי נתקע במלחמה.
וגם דה, שהם
נגינת פסנתר
וגם נתנה שיעורים. כאן אי אפשר להעביר כספים.
כך הדודה שלי הייתה מעבירה להם כספים, אבל כל שנות המלחמה
הייתה כל שנות המלחמה בברלין.
הרבע בבקשה.
מצד שני, רק אתה משפרת את כל הקונצרטים של ניקי שבשנת,
ויש שם הרבה תרבות.
חזרה ב
הנושא של הפסנתר היה מאוד חשוב בחיים שלה, כי זה היה
והוא
היה בשנתם. היום נותנים היום עם בני המושבה.
היו באים לשמוע את נחמה, לא נקבל הגז היה מפגש. כן,
זה כבר
זה כבר ש מרגולין היה
בהגנה. מפקד הגדוד הראשון ליהודה.
כן, כן, נכון. זאת לפני הגנה
לפני. הבינו. תודה.
תודה. אבא שלי היה שלי שלא
יודע שזה רגע, אז עכשיו אני מבין כאן עניין
של
אבא שלך בעצם
ממש מגיע לארץ בעקבות הגדודים, בעקבות הגדולה.
זה
צמוד ל מרגולין.
ואז הוא קם, הגדוד הראשון ליהודה,
זה מעניין. והוא לוקח אותו
מכיוון שהוא עם הקשרים שלוקח אותו לקונצרט. ברר
איזה סיפור פנטסטי.
תראה, אמא שלי הייתה נראה לך אמא שהייתה
מאוד נאה? דודתי היתה פחות נאה, אבל גם כן נשים, בנות
כאלה, ועם עיניים מאוד מאוד כחולות. כל הכבישים, יש להם
עיניים כחולות.
וזה היה
בית מאוד.
אני שואלת את עצמי כי אני
ביליתי הרבה ברחובות כבר בדור יותר, אבל
ברחובות של
אמא שלי ענדה בקונסרבטוריון. שולמית, אתה יודע את כל צוות היום בתל אביב,
של אשתו של רופי.
אוקיי,
בנווה צדק,
על גבול אין וצדק. אשתו הראשונה של ארתור רופין, שהייתה
ממקור על נדמה לי וינאי או גרמני,
שנאת את הארץ. אבל הוא התחתן איתה.
ואם
פתחה
קודם
כל צוות תיאום למוזיקה
ואמא שלי בתור ילדה, אולי בת
אף פעם לא שותה יותר. היא הייתה מגיעה מרחובות לתל אביב, אולי
גיליאן.
היא
למדה בקונסרבטוריון של
של
ג'וזף סול. זו ימי
רופאים להסתכל פעם
שולמית רופין רגע, שמו הפרטי של אביך?
תראי, יש
ג'ינקס.
שזה שהם
גו'אי.
גו'אי לחלוטין. כן,
יש. לאבא שלי היה אלכס ו נורמן.
אבל אחר כך היו בנות,
ואריק שעומד וג'ו יש
ורואה
ג'ודית אחת הייתה ג'ודית, ונייה
והם
אלה
לא היו
ישראל הזה בגד ואולי בינלאומית
מאוד.
כן, אם אין עוד טמבל זו מהר מאוד בדובאי.
האנשים האלה בדור אחד מ
את יודעת, כי כש
לפני ש עכשיו שמעתי את הסיפור הזה, התמונה שאם היית שואל אותי על ג'וליוס
ג'ייקוב זה
הוא, הייתי אומרת
יהודי בריטי חסר קשר לארץ שהגיע לכאן כי בריטי
עכשיו
לא, זה שיפוי.
תראה, יש לי
יש לי מכתבים שלו כתבה
אני לא לא מדבר עד הרבה חפירות הוא היה מפשל מדי במלחמות החינוך לאורך
עצם זה שהוא מתגייס הלימודים העברי לא כי במאי
כן,
אני אגיד לך
אחר כך
כשאני כבר הייתי, נמצא את ליין דעה, אז
היה לי דוד נורמן
שהיה מאוד מאחר גדול בהסתדרות הציונית. באמת ששתי בעוד דוד
הוא מגדל,
אולי אנשי לדודה שלי
גם כן
פעיל, והם קרניות ציונים. אבל זה היה בשנות ה
ה
זה כבר היה.
אני יכול להגיד לך עוד דבר, כי אני יודעת את זה.
כשאבא שלי
התחתן עם אמא שלי לבד היום, עד עשרים והם התחתנו בשנת הוא היה כמה
הם היו כאן.
הוא היה עוד שנה בצבא.
הם גרו בשער, פרק
ב
באמצע אזור ואחת אחרי הפרעות
אחרי מאורעות של
מתי היו המורה
המתחיל בפסח? לא ההורים שלך? אחד. למה
אנחנו ההורים שלי חיים
התחתנו בינואר,
יש להם בריכה
גם ובשר אתן באוהל.
שם היה
בשער הפן
והם
המשפחה
אמרה לו לחברו במדבר
מצא שם איזה
פלשתינאית, איזה מנהיג.
איכן יש שם יש הגדוד
שהממשלה
לא רק נזק. אחת הסיבות
למה הגדוד מתפרק בעצם.
כי כשהתחילו הפרעות ביפו
הם יצאו להזמין את היהודים.
אז זה היה זה היה היום. זה לא ידעתי בוטות את הבגידה
אתם הצטרפתם, אתם הלכתם.
הלא זאת את ההילה לפירוק הגדולות
והיוצאים שלו. הקים זה הגנה.
כן,
אז הם עזבי,
אני לא כאן. יש לך את כל הפרטים כי אבי עבר כל משלבים,
אז שהוא עזב את
הצבא,
יש לבדוק אם הן כספים.
את האוניברסיטה העברית
הקימו ב
וכולם יודעים
מאיפה.
אבל הפקולטה
לכימיה.
אם ויצמן הוקמה ב
ואבי קרא לאבא שלי ואבא שלי היה מרצה לכימיה
במשך שנתיים,
מישהו פה היה של הכימיה.
כן,
ויש לי אפילו
מישהו הוציא לי דף
של האוניברסיטה.
מי היה עצבני
מאוד אנגלית,
ואחר כך
הוא עבר עד שהוא הגיע לממשלה
הועבר
אחרי.
אני לא יודע למה. אחרי שנתיים השונים, שנתיים וחצי
הוא עבר בעבר
גם
במחלקה המדינית של הסוכנות בבדים ארלוזורוב,
ואז עד
נדמה לי, אוסום,
ואז לדברי אמו שלי,
אבל אנחנו,
היא אומרת לי
הם לא שילמו, כבר היו שני אחי ואני
כבר לא יבקש. והיעד שיאופינג
המנדט.
אז הוא הגיש בקשה לעבוד במדע,
ואז התקשר.
הוא. אז הוא התחיל להיות משהו. כבר. ארץ ישראלי לחלוטין.
כל כך הרבה שכבר כמה שנים בארץ.
שמונה
מה? כמעט עשר,
עשר, עשר, עשר מיישרים. משווה ישראל רישום בשיטה
הזאת תגיע לכאן. כן, החונק יין
הוא חייל
לחזור,
לא החמקן. ועד אז הוא
כן
לפנטז. לא, זה גם כן. תראה,
להגיד לך ישראלי
קודם כל הייתה פה. מה היה פה? מנדט.
העברית שלו
כן
הייתה תמיד עם הקטנטן, בלי נוער
ו בבית ההורים שלי. אמא שלי למדה יותר מהר
אנגלי, כמו שאבא שלי אייברי
היה קורא את הארץ כל בוקר. אבל אני לא חושבת שבימים עברו כראש ספר
והשתתף. קרה. אמון
המון ספרות
אנגלית ושירה, אנגלית,
מידע,
אבל
קר אנגלית. כל הספרים שניתן להם בבית היו
בחדר של אבא שלי. היו באנגלית. כן,
זהו. אה,
אבל זה הייתה הייתה תקופת למדד. הוא חי.
אז רגע, אתה מכורה? לא.
ביום הכי היה בחוק
הכי נולד ב
לא איתנו.
אחי נהרג. הטייס
הכי חלק מהעולם
מההיסטוריה של ישראל היה
אני
אגיד לך בסוגריים
אחי,
יש לנו לחיל האוויר הבריטי,
כלומר, תנטוש ברוג'ר כמו איזה זר, וכל העם נגד השוחד וכל הבנק הזו.
אני
לא השפית. איימי
היה חדשי
לא הספיק להילחם גמרא ממני ב
ונשלח לאנגליה
טיש.
אחרי שהשתחרר ב
הוא הלך לאוקספורד
על מלגה,
וב
פנו אליו.
אז מישהו תאשים
ו
אמרו לו אנחנו צריכים אותך, אתה צריך לשאול. צ'כיה
עזב את
את אוקספורד
בשקט, ואני
הייתי סטודנטית בלונדון.
הלכתי והסברתי לה,
אלא רקטור של
הכולל שלו, שאחי מנסה לישראל, כי אמא שלי יכולה.
אין טלפונים, אין יסיטו. ואחי היה בית שחיו הביתה.
אשפית עם מקף. כבר
ברור הזה שגברים האלמנה
אמא על מה שכן
ברגע
זה.
אז אתה אומר לי על אחי. ואחר כך
הוא היה פה במלחמת השחרור ב
הוטש פעמיים או שלוש,
שהחיה הבית הם
נטושים אחר כך אם נלחם פה
ונטשת מעבר מהבי ח, אני מייג'ר, וכל זה נראה רע.
קראו לו.
אחר כך הוא חזר ללונדון.
בחדר היה כשעוד למד משפטים, חזר פה
אותי רישיון. עבד בחיפה אצל יעקב סולומון
וכל מה היה עושה מילואים.
וב
קראו לו מיליונים.
אני רק ברמת אביב,
בתי קוף.
שלושה משתים, או
בשמו הפרטי צ'אנג
הבן שלי מיקרון
זמן ויש בו
יש לבן
ועוד
נשאר לנו שמשפחה ג'ייקוב
גם היה
שם.
אז בעצם היום את השם ג'ייקוב אין מי שיש
לו אין
לו מהמשפחה לא מא אני
אגיד לך
יש אם אתה שואל על שם
וכשסיפרתי לילדים הם לא ידעו
כשאחי היה ואני מצאתי את הדוקרן
כששלחו אותו לצ'כיה
זה היה השעש מאוד כל הסיפור הזה
אז הוא
שנתנו לו דוק אם הן כן
מזויף
הוא היה צריך לבחור שם.
הוא
קרא לעצמו
שחר.
למה
אני לא יודעים את זה מעניין
כששב היא
אנגלי
הגיע
למי פולניה לאנגליה
היה היה השם המשפחה שלי עשבי הים עונה
הוא היה ילד בן שתים
הוא נכנס לעבוד במשפחה של החברה מר טקסטים ושם היה ג'ייקוב
אז
הוא שינה את שמו התחתן עם הבת
אל מונעת
זה
זה היה שם בעצם החג הכי לך ידע את הסיפור אנחנו כולנו יהיה לנו את הסיפור של
סבא
שיני שמונה שם שאינה אשתו
ו
ואז
ואז אחי לקח את זה ויש לי יודע אני יודעת זה קשור לאמון לחשוב
מונעת מונט שש ש
חודש
שעבר
בגרמנית מונאטי
בגרמני התמונות
הם היו פולנים אבל היום שהן יותר גם אני
לא ישר הבנתי שחשוב לימון, אבל לא ידעתי באיזה אז הם עוד קנמון להסתכן בדיוק את זה,
נדמה לי שמונת שגם בגרמנית, שגם חודש. וגם
אה כנראה כן גם לזה.
כמו בעברית שם
רגע כן שר
כן.
אז הכינה שליט שחי את. יש לי
את הדרכון שלו המזוין.
טוב,
אבל זה כן, אך יישאר בכל המלחמות
שהפציץ את הגב.
אז הוא גדול ממך בכמה,
שלוש וחצי שנים
ולא לילד לשנה ארה ב.
אז אז בואו נחזור עכשיו
להורים
בשנות ה
סוף ה
סוף פשוט עשרים סופי
שאתם
שאחיך נולד
ב
בראשה בירושלים.
אבי עבר על ירושלים כי קודם הוא היה באוניברסיטה
ואני חושבת שעובד באוניברסיטה עוד
והוא לדחייה הכימיה,
נכנסתי.
ואז הוא אז הוא פנה. אז אני לא יודעת את
ארלוזורוב. אם היו חברים של הוריי,
הם היו היה ירושלמי. אני זוכרת את שימה ארלוזרוב, את הבת שלהם
ברחוב.
היא בין האזורים להרוג
לפני שהם עפו לתל אביב והרגו אותו.
באיזה שנה רגולטורים לשנוא אותך
טוב,
אז אבי עבד כי יועץ אוקי
אני לא יכול להגיד לך
אין אף פעם ירושלים.
אני עולה שעבודים או לעזוב.
ואז יש את הפתיחה
תפתח לו
במשרד הממשלתי למנדט
יש לי גם כן את
הניירות שאבי
ש שנותן כמיקלים ויטי הוא פונה
וכבר תדפקי.
נכנס מזמיני שאחד התפקידים הראשונים היה דייסתי
לא אופה.
אופה
מקטין מחוז כזה
אחר כך הוא היה
אני הייתי ילדה. אני הייתי תינוקת. אני לא יודעת את התקופה הזאת.
אחר כך היתה תקופה.
זה כבר לתוך שנות השלושים שהתחילה
הנאציזם.
אני יודעת את זה.
הוא היה
בא עם מגרש
ובזה אני יודעת
כי הוא היה מכיוון שזו היתה משפחה מוזיקלית מאוד
גם בירושלים. מהמם, פסנתר. היו קונצרטים וכל המוזיקאים היו באים הביתה
אני
אבא שלי עזר מאוד ל הוברמן
הוא באמונה הבעיה
להביא מדענים ולשדר להם שטבעי קטין.
הוא היה מאוד מקורב לאנשי התזמורת
טוסקניני עוד אני זוכר אותו,
אבל
זה היה בית מוזיקלי מאוד
ואחר כך
הוא עבר את
לרסק את תראי
מה שקוראים
המזכירות הראשי
ויש לנו
נכדי
אדוני אבל עוד לפני זה כן,
הוא היעד במזכירות ולאט לאט הוא עלה גבוה מאוד היום אבל אני אומר את זה אני לא רוצה לקפוץ
למשהו שאני רוצה לשלם לו ריי לפני
הוא כבר היה
שנקרא בשלוש אה
כבר היה נחשב לאחד התפקידים
הגבוהים אחרי
היהודים חשב הכי גבוה הכי גבוה
עכשיו
כי
אני רוצה לשאול שאלה רגע אחת לסופנו פשוט
בוא נחזור עכשיו אני הולך הגאלה,
אלא איך באופן אישי
הכל בסדר בשבע.
וכאדם
בינך לבין עצמך
איזו תמונה
ראשונה יש לך הזיכרון הראשון
זה אולי לא זיכרון כי יש לי תמונה קטנה
ממושכות. איפה הם
כש
כן,
עד. עד
שהוריי בנו את הבית.
נכון. בין מאמינים ששם גר אחר כך ב
ב
בן גוריון וגולדה. אז אני חושב שעכשיו קוראים לזה בית אשכול. עכשיו,
לפני זה
גרנו מה שהיום זה חוב. דווין מרקוס בבית
ערבי
קטן.
אני זוכרת את זה נפלא. הייתי אולי בת
שלוש. ארבע
זה היה בית.
אין
קומה אחת מדרגות משני הצדדים עם מרפסת מחדרים כאלה כמו שהיית של הערבים. בית נחמד
ולפתח את העלייה הזו.
הייתה
עוד דירה קטנה
ויש שם ילד עם ממני. ואני זוכרת שאחי ואני היינו משחקים.
אבל זה
הרבה שנים זכרתי את שמו.
כן
שגרנו שם בשכונה הזו. זה היה
רק
כאן שיהודים
בהמשך בעל פה, אתה יודע, כדי אדם,
תיאטרון הירושלמי של
אחד על אחד הבתים.
אני אגיד לך מי גר שם. אחר כך
טייט
ג'יין אייר המשורר.
גם שם אחר כך אנחנו באנו לבקר אותי. ואמרתי לו 'אני. בילדותי גרתי שם.
אז יש איזה מין זיכרון של הבית
הערבי הזה
אם ילד ארמני.
זה היה
הגבול של רכבי. אתה מבין, היה שם
לו גם
מה שהיה היום מהרחוב בעל פה גם כן. היה כולו
זרים
שלם. משפחת שלנו. אני זוכרת את משפחת שונה ממשנהו.
שני הילדים
היו לא
למדו באיזה פאב לקס כל באנגליה היו באים לחופש.
ובכן,
זה היה
גבולי. היה שם הרבה ערבים נוצרים
לאיזה
גן הוא בית ספר ואני זוכרת כי זה
דאון כך כי היה לנו מועדון.
בשנות השלושים
הגיע
לישראל
מחנכת
אלן קליין,
אמריקאית
שגמרה כל מיני אשכולות כמו פיסטולות שלי וכל החינוך החדש.
ופתחה
גם בבית הספר
הרבה רחוב מליסנדה. מה שהיום רשות השידור בארמון הזה
כשאני זוכרת כמו היום
ואני מ גיל
ארבע
או חמש הלכתי,
היה שם
גם גן
עם מכנסי אתה מכיר את הבניין הזה
היום? איך קוראים לזה? המלכה משהו שלומית, אמרתי,
אנחנו קראנו לזה מנכ ל
הולי ג'יין מליסנדה
המונח אבא שהיא הגדול כן, כן.
ואנחנו ביתו בגן הילדים
היינו אוכלים צהריים
ואחר כך היו פותחים מיטות
כאלה לבנות.
היינו צריכים לשאול,
והאוכל היה מגעיל
אם אני
אגיד משהו כזה לא, זה המון ייסורים.
לא? אני לא יודע איזה שיטה ניתן לשפר לך את השיטה שכבר למדתי בבית ספר שם
מי למד איתנו
מכרז מורה. ואין דבר דאג רונסקי הבא של הגרון
ורפאים בלומנפלד אבל
זה היה בית ספר.
בואו נגיד ת'אמת.
והשוק, נקעים ילדים והרוב פינים,
זה העניין בית ספר אליטיסטי
הוא ממש משמע אין קגני,
נכון?
כן,
כן, כן. אני זוכרת אותה
עם משקפת על
רווקה
כי זה משך כי
לא מדברים עליה.
אני
אני זוכר את זה נהדר,
אך
שני והיא
וכל משפחת יעילים ובין תביט שלמתים שם הם אומרים לך שמודעי באמת
זה היה הבורג. אנו את אפילו
לא כל כך עוד
התחילו לפני אייק אם
מה שמעניין עד שהיום אתה הולך למקומות כמו רמת השרון משפט
מבין את האנתרופוסופיה. ויש את כל המקום
אחת
חיים בתחושה שזה קרה בעשרים שנה האחרונות.
אבל זה היה כאן. בית שבו אני אקבל
עכשיו.
אחר כך עברתי. אני לא מרגיש שם עד גיל
בערך
עכשיו
היה
והכיתות הגדולות האלו. כשהתחלתי ללמוד בבית ספר,
בקושי עמדתי
בכושית. אתם ביקרו
בכיתה א' ב' ג'. זה לא כל כך עניין אותם.
היה לה
בביתה
היה נגרות.
אך אנחנו את זה והמורים מנגנות
נגרות עם הידיים הגדולות היה תופס אותנו. היה
שיפר
שהיה אמן ידוע אחר כך,
אבל הוא קיבל את הרוויח. הצלחנו לעבוד עם בית ספר קלים.
היה
היו עושים
הצגות,
היו משקיעים בהצגות,
ואני אחרת
רבים, לא מבין
שהיה
אחר כך. הוא היה ארכיטקט.
כן,
והיה מאוד רכשתי.
הוא עזר
בנו מודל
של העיר עתיקה מעץ. אז השקענו חצי על. כל הילדים התעסקו בזה. אני לא יודע כמה
כמה תלמידים היו בבית הספר הזה
על העניין.
אני אגיד לך,
בני אני כי אנחנו
מ שמי שלמד בבית ספר, זה שאמר אחר כך רצינו מועדון
שהשקיעו עמום אנשים. הצלנו
אותה. פנטסטית,
אבל כרוך טוב בקוטר
ולא היו שיעורי בית.
כלומר, יש שיעורי בית.
והן היה חדר עם עוד
הן את הנברשת לבדוק
איך מתקדם כמה פרויקטים.
ככה זה נראה לי היום.
אני זוכרת,
היקאפ, פרטי, כמובן. או לבית ספר פרטי. אני לא יודע, לא שאלתי.
כן,
בטח אותי.
עכשיו אני אגיד לך.
אני
בדיוק
היה הארמון הזה של חדשים
למעלה בטייגר גם הגרון. מי שהיה אחר כך ראש העיר
הייתה יהודית, וברגע ויום
ג'וני ג'וני הגדול לא, אחר כך כרתו לו, נפטרו הבריגדה
ואנחנו היינו
בורחים מבית הספר
ורצים לה
למשפחת דרגונטי וכובשים לטווח החצר.
נדמה לי שגם האיונים ו שפנים נדמה לי
מאוד מודרני
עכשיו,
כי כנראה לא עמדה ב
בתשלומים,
ואני אני
יודעת שחברה שלי, מיכל זמורה, ברוחב לבלום, נפעל בכל אלה
כבר לא יימשכו. אני המשכתי,
כי אחר כך הצטמצמה
באסטר בית ספר
ברחוב אלחריזי. היה שם איזה בניין לשתף. אני עוד הייתי שם עוד איזה שנה.
זה כבר איבד את כל
הפנטזיה הזו של להיות בתוכנית בתוך החצר הגדולה הזו והבית הגדול הזה
בשנת
הוריי נסעו לאנגליה
ואני
לכמה חודשים, ואני ישבתי לדודתי ברחובות
ולמדתי בבית ספר עממי ברחובות,
בימין,
שם למדתי,
הייתי כבר בזה,
הייתי כבר בהן.
בת עשר כמעט
כמעט
ושם,
שם עמדתי לכתוב בלי קול.
אין
זאת אומרת בבית ספר היום.
כאן זה
חופשי. חוקים
אז אתה צריך להסתכל. יש לוקמן,
אחר כך אני מזיכרוני. אני יודעת,
כשגם הבית ברחוב אלחריזי נסגר ונשתה איזה פרויקט.
כן, כן,
אחת כזה רוחנית,
כי אתה יודע,
אני זוכרת איך היא נראית
ושנים אחרי זה
כמה מהחברות האלה שלנו
היינו נפגשות לצהריים? זה היה
בקבוצה,
כולל רובין
ושמורה.
וכל אלה שלמדו בתיבה עם
מיכל מיכל בואי, גם את החברה שלי לחדר. כהן
אני
היא הייתה. היא מבוגרת ממני בשנתיים מתח
והיה רופאים שהם בשנה מעליי. אבל הייתה קבוצה שלמה שעמדה ואינו
חושב צהריים אחת לחודש, אבל לאט לאט
זו קיבלה עזרה, אינם יודעים, חלתה וזו מתה. פשוט לא היה.
אפילו צירפנו את טראומה שלא למדה, שאמרו אלמנדה במשמר העמק
כדי לשמור.
אין הזמיר, אשתו של צביקה זמיר,
שאבא שלי היה
דוקטור אוסטרובסקי עם
הגניקולוג שהיא ילדת כל, את כל ירושלים
סדובסקי
שילדת קול ירושלים באר.
אז תכניס את זה
בשביל אחד.
זה באמת אני אומר לך,
רק עוד נשארו.
לי עוד
הייתה עוד אחת ג'יי כקצין הראשון,
אבל ש
בדודה של שמוליק תמיר. אבל הם היו
בפנים כי אם לא לא ניקוד. ניקי מקצין הראשון
נשאלנו, קרא לעצמו אחר כך
היא. אבל אני
לא יודע מי עוד חייב לי בעל שלנו,
אז כבר לא נשאר
בשלוש.
אני רוצה שזו שאלה לתקופה ב
כשהתחילו מאורעות להשפיע את זוכרת משהו
המון. אני זוכר.
ואני אגיד לך למה. כי יש לי זיכרון מאוד בולט.
קודם כל,
אנחנו לא רעיון.
היה רכב.
אני אומר אבא שלי או סטן. כאדון
היינו אנשים אל מול לרחובות.
זה היה
קודם. כל הבית של
דודה שלי גרה, אז היא כבר התחתנה עם שמי לאנסקי
זה תחת שר של שישה וחצי דונם
בחכירה נעדרת מכאן, מתקשים גדולים כרגע,
לא מטופחת.
והיו שנים לדודתי היו שתי פרות ותרנגולות בגן גן ירק.
זה היה
גן עדן. היינו נשים הרבה, לא רחובות,
וישבת שלי
דון במקום היתה
מחלקת בזמנה. בן דודה שאני מבין, ירושלים מתה.
התחלתי שנה פה, חצי שנה פה.
אז היינו אנשים הרבה. עכשיו היינו נוסעים דרך רמאללה,
רמלה,
אני זוכרת מצוין. היינו שמדברים
היו זורקים אבנים,
היינו מפחדים,
וכן מסוכן.
עכשיו יש לי זיכרון.
זה
כן. זה
מאוד בשביל ילדתי.
אני כבר למדתי בגימנסיה
ברחביה.
אני לא זוכרת אם זה היה
שבע. שמונה
לא אמרתי.
חזרתי יום אחד, מי
מהן
בגימנסיה הייתי
מה הייתם זורק את האיכות שלי.
לאבא שלי היה חדר המונע את זרקת
את
ההשלכות.
היה
זה שקט
היו שהעבירה, ואבא שלי היה בבית.
ואז הם סיפרו לי
שאבינו
ירו ב אבינועם ילין
והוא נפטר.
עכשיו. אבינועם ירד. היה בן
הזקונים של דוד ילין,
ילד קיפוחם
לומר את קיימברידג
במדעי המזרח.
מאוד משקיעים.
זה עבד במחלקת. את
החינוך של המנדט
לקחו אותו.
הוא היה נשוי לאישה בשם אלייזה
ולא היו להם ילדים. אתה יודע על דיברו ככה? אז בשקט ל חשוב
למי שלא היה ילדים הוא כבר היה אולי בן
או משהו כזה. אבל
באמת
ציפו ממנו
המזריק מבריק.
הוא גם מוציא איזה ספר כששכחתי
וזה יפה. כולם דיברו על השטח
ואני הם גרו קרוב מאד אלינו.
ואני אהבתי אותם והם אהבו אותי. הייתי מבקרת אותם. איבדנו את אבינועם ואעזוב.
האם הם
לא היו להם ילדים? ואני
יודע, מתוקה. בתי בת שמונה, תשע הייתי
החרשת אליהם והם יודעים מישהו כריות. והיה להם את קטן מעבר
זה כשהורה הודיעו לי,
לא דיברו הרבה על מוות. אז בא
איש תראו מהילדים מהבית. ואיכשהו זה
אני הבנתי.
ירו בו במשרד המשרד הממשמש טדי הממשלה היו אז בשער שכם.
היה בית גדול.
אני זוכרת בפינה.
ואחרי שזה עבר,
לא היה שם מקום שהוא כאן.
יש חשיבות לזה. זה אותי. ואחר כך הלכתי
עם הוריי
לישיבה
של משפחת כלים ולראות את זה
היום מול אנשים.
דוד ילין
הוא היה
נחשב כזה
כן,
הם גמרו
מתים. מקור ברוך הוא
בשכונות האלה שם.
זוכרת שהלכתי, מוריי?
זה היה
פעם הראשונה שנפגשנו
שנפגשתי ככה עם מוות
שמישהו שהיה
אני רואה כמו דוד מבוגר נורא אהבתי אותם
יותר.
אז ככה אני זוכר את המעורבות
שיאמרו לו בבטן.
כלומר,
זה
זה כשההורים עוד היו פה,
ואז אנחנו נוסעים
לאנגליה
לא דומה, אה,
אתה יודע את זה. אני
אני לא אני לא אני לא יודעת את זה. היינו זו היו היו בבית. בטח חברתי.
לא, הם נסעו. תראה
בזמן
אבא שלי. על מה? על הזמן.
אבא שלי בתור
עובד המנדט שהוא התחיל להיות עובד המנדט. כשאני חושבת
שלושים אולי
התקבל
כי בריטי
כל שנתיים היה לו מה שנקרא הוא מלהיב.
היה לנו שנייה.
לא היה להם חופש
בשנתיים,
תוך שכל שנתיים
קיבלו כמעט חודשיים
היינו נשים באניות. אני ישנתי מגיל שנתיים. הייתי, למשל טען כי
היינו נוסעים.
כן,
ללונד
לוקחים רכבת ליעד כאן טרה.
ובכן, אתה
הולך יחד עם זה כאן, טרה אבל
היו עוברים את איפה עוברים את התעלות
ומגיעים לפורט סעיד, ושם היינו לוקחים מוניות לעונג.
והיינו נוסעים בטח שלושה שבועות באוניה
ואז היינו נוסעים לראות אותה שם. אז חשבתי
אז הורי לשוב
ב
וב,
אבל אז שהם לא התבלבל בגלל בית הספר שלי או משהו.
אמרו לי כי
אפילו רחובות והוא עבר גלגולים בשבילי.
מתי את הגעת לאנגליה?
לא ללמוד. אני הגעתי בערך
בסוף המלחמה ב
אז
זה נכון.
אז את נוסעת לתקופה? לרחובות.
אוקיי,
הורי חזרו. הם הזכירו את הבית
מרחב ירה
לעבר וואו, כאילו, נגיד חודשיים שלושה
חודשיים באנגליה ואני
וחזרו להיות אומר
ואחרי זה
תיכף
מתחיל לעזוב את זה אז את
יותר לא נסענו
אבא שלהם מ
לא ניילון עכשיו זה
לגבי
משפחה באירופה המשפחות מכיר מה קורה איתם
אז
אפילו לא דיברו על
אתה יודע אבל
לא יודע לא, לא דיברו. כלומר, לא דיברו מהמהפכה הרוסית
אני לא שמעתי
אני יודעת שאין דודתי
נשאת פעם ברוסיה עוד לפני המהפכה רצו להרחיק אותם בשבילן שלי כנראה המשפחה.
והיא הייתה כמה חודשים
מה שהיה לי כאב לראותם
משפחה אבל זה היה עולה
בשלוש שש
לפני המלחמה אומרים לא נגעו,
לא דיברו אני רוצה לדעת
אביך
איש בתוך המנדט הבריטי
אנחנו,
רדיפות היהודים, מתחילה
אנחנו אנחנו
חווים את כל היקרים שבאו
כל יום הייתי גרועה
ירושלים הייתה מלאה
נבטים של ניק אם שהצליחו לברוח אז לפני המלחמה.
לכן
ברגע שהתחילה המלחמה כבר
אז תראה, המלחמה,
אתה יודע
לאן
שנות הארבעים, חיילי הענק
על הרדיפות הנתשי
יהודי גרמניה יכלו לעזוב אותי?
כן, אז אז עזבו.
אם אני מכירה את האנשים,
חלק מהאנשים שבאו עם הפסנתרים והשרים והשינה על הגב והוא מתחיל הקונפליקטים.
המנדט
בעצם
שהעם היהודי נמצא בעצם
בנקודה מאוד מאוד קשה,
כי מצד אחד
אפשר לעזוב את גרמניה.
מצד שני הבריטים
לא יכולים לבטל ולא נותנים שם, כי בדיקות על הדרך הערבית
והיהודים משלמים את המחיר.
איך את רואה את זה בעיניים שלך? היסטורית
זה מאוד דילמה בשבילי. תראה, קודם כל אני יודעת
ולא כותבים על זה. היא חוץ משרת וציפור השאר ועוד מישהו שכתב
אבא שלי.
בשביל
שונות יש
לפנות המלחמה.
היה לו תפקיד מאוד חשוב,
מיוחד
שנקרא.
הוא היה משקיע הבו שפליי בעוד
הקימו ב
נדמה לי אולי
ועדה
חשובה מאוד עם ג'ורג' וולש'
שנהרג גם כן
פיצוץ סכין. דיוויד,
לנסות
לפתח
תעשייה היא
יהודי.
אולי
שמישהו אמר לי ששילבו גם ערבים. כן, בשביל. בשביל
שיווי משקל.
לפתח תעשייה
שתספק
דברים.
צבאות הברית במצרים ובמדבר.
עכשיו אני יודעת את זה אישית. אז הוא עמד בראש המנגנון. להוריי המשקיעים,
המזכיר הכללי, זה היה תפקיד
מאוד חשוב. כן, הוא היה
האיש
היהודי.
כשאני אני יודעת את זה אישית.
בבקשה.
אני מאוד אהבתי לערבי. היה איש מאוד שקט
ובאישה
ולא דברן גדול.
יש משקיעים
והיינו ביחד, ואני הייתי בדיוק להיפך באופן שלילי,
אבל
אותי הוא היה כבוי.
הוא היה
מחופש אבלון.
אני זוכרת. יש לי גם תמונה
שנישאנו ל
הם
בית חרושת לשיש ברמת גן, ופגשנו את האחים בו ז'אן הו. אז היו הבולגרים
לבולגרים
יש תמונות של אבא שלי בודק.
וכאן אורים,
ריבות ושימורים בשביל שנה
אחר כך משכתי אותו פעם
בסיס נחשב ב
המפעל הגדול ביותר בארץ.
אז
אז עשו גם נדמה לי מלפפונים חמוצים בדברים כאלה.
מי את, ריבות. רבעון
אחר כך נסענו לגבעת חיים. אני זוכרת את זה כמו היום
יש לנו לגבעת חיים. היה שם מפעל של ריבות,
ואני זוכר הנדודים גדולים
של ריבת
זה נראה כמו שזיפים כהים, בקע
ובודקים. אני הולכת,
אני אקדמאי. לא חושב פרני מ אני בת, את בת כמה
אחוז שלא יודעים מה ב לא לעבוד עם מה
ומדברים שם, ואחר כך נשארתי איתו לאפיקים.
באפיקים היה מפעל לבד עם של עץ
גם כן.
ואז
אני כך שיפרתי את זה. זה לא שאני
מגלה
לשם,
כי אני זה היה נורא דומיננטי בחברה.
ואז יום אחד, ואני זוכרת שאבא שלי חוזר
התרגשות גדולה ואומר לי עם עם
אמא שלי נהג הלאה. מה
האמת שמעון ווילפרד.
הוא הלך
ופגש בדרום תל אביב.
זה
מפעל קטן, עלוב, כי הוא אמר לנו באיזה תנאים
עם האיש הזה עובד
את מי שהיה
מהנדס הראשי.
חושב שזה האיש עיקול בגרמניה. גולדברג
הוא אבי
ההיי טק הישראלי.
הוא איש ידוע מאוד. בינתיים
הוא כבר לא חי.
הוא היה
גרמני שהצליח לברוח. הוא היה מהנדס הראשי של שיש.
אז היי, שהיתה חברת
המצלמות
והוא הקים את
הזריזות סאליס טייס שייט.
אנחנו בוודאי שיכון, היו ברורים על זה. יש לזה
זה
בגרמנית,
אומרים צ'ייס. תאי סיליקון
כמה שנים ארוך להתרגש,
והוא התחיל לחשוב מכל מיני אופטי כל
כך ומתחיל באופטיקה.
וכמעט
הייתי תסתכל על
בגוגל על איזה וכולם למוצאו נייר.
אבי הוא בעצם הוא טיפח את כל אחר כך שנכנסו על ידי הרוסים.
אז הרוסים הפכו את זה לכמה
קרב, אבל הוא היה טוב והוא תיקח אחר כך
משרד הביטחון לקח אותו וכל זה.
אבל אבל
אבל אני חושב שאני צריך לרשום. אנחנו נרשם רק את השמות גם של המורה.
עוד פעם את שמו של גולדברג,
אבל שמו הפרטי אני לא זוכרת, אבל עם תאים טשטשה גולדברג, אופטיקה. אתה תקבל את זה.
כן. כן, זה מופיע בדלפק
כי יותר מדי דברים מעניינים. אני שומע היום.
רגע, אני צריכה לתקן לו שאעמוד? כן.
לא אני.
הוא בפגישה.
יש עוד דרך.
איזה פתק?
אתה מוצא את זה פה, ג'קי?
כן.
וואו.
תשתכן גולד אופטיקה. זה יביא לך כמו כלום
אחת. רגע.
תודה.
הנה, קח.
אני
אני חוזרת לאשר
שיש
חוזר לשאלה הזו של אמביוולנטיות.
כן,
של
אז בימי המלחמה
אבא שלהן נורא שהוא הוא נעשה כמעט
כל חודש חודשיים למצרים. הוא היה נוסע קש עם השיפוט הזה. אני לא יודע.
אני ישנתי
עם יש לי מעניין ישן עם אבא שלי כמה פעמים
אפילו לפני אלא למין. הייתי מצרים.
הוא לא לוקח אותנו. היינו בשפעת שהולכות משטרת קפה במתקפה מסתובבות שם
היו לאבא שלי כמה חברים.
היה יהודי
עשיר מאוד שהיה קרוב למלך. עוד היה
זה
שהפרתי את שמו שהייתה לו בת בגיל.
אז
אבא שלהם
הוא הוזמנו אך קשה בזמן המלחמה
ו
והוא
בנוסף להכל
לקראת
שרת
ו קפלן ודב יושב.
והם
היו באים מינינו יושבים בחדר משוננים ואני יודעת שאבא שלי היה
יש
הוא ישב על שני כסאות,
היה לו מאוד קשה
יש לזה סוף
הסוף הוא היה רע, אבל
אם הייתי את שום הממון יש מכתבים שנשרת שכותב הממשלה
כשאבא שלי נערה, אני, ג'וליוס
אומר
וגם בכתובים שלו שהוא
היה מספק להם
אינפורמציה
לא ממש על המצב. אני לא חושבת שאבא שלי הוא
מסוג האנשים שהיה מוק'
אניית בסוגריים. אני אגיד לך
ב.
אבא שלה,
אחרי אחרי המלחמה הוא קיבל חופשה. נסענו ללונדון. אני נדרשתי ללמוד
הכי עוד היה בחיל אוויר. אבל
זה
כבר
להתקבל לאוקספורד
ו
אביך חזר. אמא שלי נשארה איתי כי הייתי בת שמונה עשרה לראות איך אני מסתדר.
וכשהוא היה באנגליה,
הציעו לו ג'ורג
מישהו שהוא הכיר מהראש הפלאי, בעוד הזה
יציינו ג'וב נפלא.
ואמא שלי היתה צברית,
אמרה זאת שוב יש,
קח את זה
משקורה טובה,
אני באנגליה, הילדים לומדים פה.
ככה שזה
ואבא שלי אמר לך
מה פתאום. אני אני חושב במקום שלי בארץ.
וכשהוא חזר
לארץ ועוד היה
הסגן של שור,
אני יש לי מכתב שהוא כתב לאמא שלי,
ש
הוא מודיע הראשון
שהוא צריך לעזוב, שהוא לא יכול, שזה
זה
יהיה. מישהו כתב במגזין
מאוד אנגלי קטן
שהוא
אוהב,
מתלבט. יותר מדי ל הגיעו אנדי, אולי בין דתי או
הזדהות כפולה.
הוא אמר השר שהוא
רוצה לעזוב כשהוא אמר בשום פנים לא, אבל הוא הביא אותו
אולי שבוע לפני שהוא נהרג
מ
הספטריאנית שהיה עם הפנים לעיר העתיקה. אני הייתי במשרד הזה,
לצד
המערבי מול ההורים שהיא
כאילו
ל
במחלקת הפיננסיים
ושם או נהרג,
הוא אמר. את החלק
שפונה לכיוון האלה על
החלק שבו עמד.
יש תמורות
שתראה אותה.
כולם
המון. היה
לא רק החלק החלק הדרומי,
אבל לא שחוללו העיר העתיקה. ולא היו הוסיפו אחר כך שתי קומות ששילמו די שונים.
אבל אחרי אבא שלי היה המשרד שפני ערב, ואני הלכתי.
בתור ילדה הייתי לפעמים אולי טוב, היכרויות עכשיו
הוא
חדר גדול פה. נראה עתיקת
הימים
זה יפה. יש
היה בתנע שפונה, בדיוק החלק שנראה שזה גם
בחלק שנערך לגמרי זה
ושם הוא עבר
אולי שבוע שבועיים.
אמא שלי נשארה,
היו התכתבויות
ארוכות. זה לקח הרבה זמן עד שהם מכתבים הגיעו בשנות ה.
אז?
אז אני לא חושבת שלאבא שלי היה
שוב פשוט
כשאנשים דברים נהיו קשים מאוד, היו לו התלבטויות
של מצפון,
אבל
תוך כדי השנייה
הוא ישב טוב מאוד. אני זוכרת שראית היה בה היו משתוללים.
לא, לא. בן גוריון, לדוגמה. אני חושב ההסתדרות שלי לגבי
שלטון במדע
צריך לחלק את זה לתקופות.
אם האחרונים, התקופה החשובה ביותר שמרגישים את המשמעות שלהם.
זה מה שאתה מדבר בתקופת המלחמה
התעשייה פה עבודה,
אלף חיילים
נהרגו. התגלמות
האישה.
מה שאמר בן גוריון, כאילו וכאילו לתקופה שלפני
אוקיי בנייה, לא יודעים מה יהיה המלחמה. זה
מה שקורה אחרי המלחמה,
אומרת אבא שלי כבר לא היה.
אמרו לי לחמש
חמש עד שהוא נהרג. כן,
יש כאן עניין שחלק מהאנשים שואלים
אז מה קורה עם מדינה יהודית
חברה
לבריטים, ולכן
מה שמזהם יסתדר. מה שאת אומרת עכשיו. בשלב מסוים, הוא אומר די, אני כבר לא יכול להיות טוב.
גם היום
יש לי
במכתבים
ויש,
אני אגיד לך, יש לי גם
מכתבים, כי המכתבים האישיים. אבל פה ושם הוא מכניס
שהוא ביקשו ממנו להעיד.
כשהוא חזר מאנגליה ב
ביקשו ממנו להעיד ל מה זה היה האנק, אומר קינג
מישהו מקומיים כשהוא היא
עוד בהתחלה, כי הוא נראה ביולי,
אז הוא
ביקשו ממנה, אם האדם לא אמריקני, אבל דם של הממשלה
למי שיש חשמל. נכון? נכון, נכון. לעשות שליש,
כן, לב.
כן, נכון.
אז הייתה ממשלת, מבין, איינשטיין יודע את
כל
זה. הסיפור, האבסורד הגדול, ההיסטורי שההתמודדות הגדולה שלנו בסופו של דבר
הייתה מעלים
עין מול הלב.
מה במה?
פעם מול הרוח, כשהיו צריכים לנהל את האימפריה הבריטית אחרי מלחמת העולם השנייה,
היוצרת של הגדול?
אבא שלי?
כן,
אני הייתי בליגת בזה. זה היה שאני באנגליה.
שלא יזיקו ממנו אישיות יותר מדי חזקה.
ובין אם בכלל היה
כן.
לא מבין. היה איש חזק מאוד. הוא היה איש של היה עניין ש כן, אבל להגיד שהוא לשים אותו.
שים אותו, כי שר החוץ
כן של האימפריה הבריטית בתקופה כל כך מהר אלא
אם כן
י היתה
הודו הודו קיבלה את העצמאות לפנינו
כן, כן,
כן,
כן
אני אגיד לך
היו להביא התלבטויות, אבל אני חושבת שלא
התלבטויות של איך למלא תפקיד
עם מצפון נקי
אבל לא היה לו התלבטויות לגבי ההזדהות הישראלית היהודית שלו.
תראה, אני אפילו התלבטויות זאת אומרת את רואה את זה?
אז
לא במכתבים שאני כבר הייתי בים.
למשל בסוף, כי המצב פה התחילה עוצר והתחילה ירושלים איזה מכתב שאת יכולה עכשיו
צריך לקרוא ממנו ולעבוד.
אולי
לפרשן את זה כי
אני צריכה לחפש אותו אז בדיוק משדרת אני עברתי על יש לי הרבה דברים של
אבא שלי, ואני אשמח, אתם יודעים, נשים, פגישה. אני חושב
שזה מעניין לראות
את
במקום שהם הרגישו.
תראה,
אם אבא שנהרג, ויקטור לוי,
שהיה קצת נמוך ממנו, הם היו החברים הכי טובים שהוא.
ויקטור לוי היה גם כן קצין בצבא הבריטי שבה אינה
מזרחי.
הוא נולד בטורקיה.
מי שאין
מישהו ששמו היה
ויקטור
עכשיו משפחת יהודים שנהרגו בפיגוע
או נמנע מהם היו פקידים בעצם היו. היה
למדן שהיה בחור
הרעש שאנשים שכן
אני,
אבל אני העולם היו בעצם בתפקיד.
כי כל שהיה באגף הזה, בעצם על
מה שתראה המזכירה של אבא שלי,
לבך אנחנו מאיפה נהרגה ומול שהיה אנדי
היו שישה יהודים.
אך חשבתי יותר
אולי אני
אני לא יודעת.
אני לא
אני לא יודעת
מה אחר שקשור. בבקשה.
לא
נדמה לי שהיא היתה המכה
כשאתם מזכירה של אמלי
מכוערת הרבה שנים,
נדמה לי שהיא
אולי אני מדברת שטויות. אני
פתאום בעלי אשם.
אני
והול שהיה ראש עבור ספריי בהודו היה. ועוד
היה עוד מישהו,
כמה מדענים שהיו חברים
עם הוריי
כשהוא נהרג.
ככה כשאמא שלי הייתה.
לא? כן. עכשיו אני חושבת שבתמונה, הרוב היהודי
שלי נהרגו שם היו חייבים לתפקיד כי לא היה מה לעשות באגף הדרומי
אם לא היית בתפקיד
באגף הצפוני. אז היו אורחים במלון.
לא הולכים לומר לנו מלומד, או אף אחד, אף אחד.
זה רק הבניין. תראה, את אפשר אותי פעם בזמנו,
אני
משמע מנהלת בית שום גם טרמולו אני יודע מה ראיתי שכיסו את זה למצלמה.
רעיה, רעיה ואם אהובה.
היא עייפה. היא היתה היא אמרה לראותי. אני הייתי בג'ינס
שהזהירו אותנו ומביע את אחותה
לנשום אוויר של ירושלים נסיעה קלה ככה יורשים
כן, כאשר הם היו באמת סיימתי אותה היום אגב, זה
יש את האירוע של מאה שנים למצוא
היום.
אז אם
אני פגע, אני הייתי רואה אותה פוגש עם דם
של ארז ישן עם ספר. אז היא משפרת שאתה מעודדת את העדות המוחלטת שהיתה הזרה,
כי אומרת
המנהל רץ פנימה או אחד הפנים ואמר להם רוצו לך דרגות ערעור עוגות אוהיו.
מאז שהם הגיעו למעלית
היה את הפיצוץ,
כי היה דעת שנים את ההתאבדות. קנט העזרה לא הייתה עושה את זה.
אני לא רוצה להביע דעה מן כי אמא שלי
לא מאמינה ולא מהמנהל בן גוריון בשנה
בן גוריון וישים, עוד בן דוד
בן גוריון
מפני שהוא היה שותף.
כשקוראים את זה שיפר את
ההיסטוריה. הוא נתן את האוקיי, הוא נתן. אוקיי, אז אין דבר. זה בויכוח הפוליטי ביניהם.
כן, בוא נדבר.
יש את האלמנט
בפנים מה שנקרא מי נתן את ההוראה,
מי לקח את האחריות.
ויש את השאלה מול הבריטים
הם ניתנה עזרה או לא עזר אני יודעת,
אז אז כמובן שאמא שלי לא רק שאתה לאן אנחנו יודעים שהיה
פעם רואה לג'וש להם פה את ואל
תרשום שהיה שייך. אוקיי,
שאביך הוא ההון.
הוא
הוא ברח החוצה?
אני לא יכול להגיד לך.
ההורים שלי אהבו מאוד את
את שוב.
ואשתו ליידי הגיע. תחטיף לה המון
אנשים
אמרו עליו שהוא אנטישמי לבדוק את הפיצוץ. כן,
כן, יכול להיות.
איך הוא? לא נער אביך? כן,
מישהו היה בת שנה המזרחי.
המשרדים שלו הוא לא נער שוב.
אבא שלי ישב ליד שוק קודם, לפני שהעבירו אותו לאיזה שהוא ברח.
לא עזב, לא ברח. הוא לא,
כי הוא זה שאמר אני אני פה כדי לתת פקודות ליהודים.
כן, בוא נדבר על אלה.
אני יודע מה
אני. לא ידעתי גם את,
גם את רות וגם את. אמא שלה
נפטרה עכשיו. כן,
היא נפטרה לפני שנה. אולי
נפטרה
שישי שמישהי אמרה לי הייתה תשולם מאודי. אבל ימים התחתנה שהמשפחה שלה בכלל היה
הזה. אני לא יודעת,
אני פגשתי. אתה
דניס, אני חושב
באמת על מה שדיברנו.
אגב, אין קשר ל קיפניס לקיפי, שם שורר אצלכם.
אני
אני לא יודעות
בעקיפין אישים שאולי כולם, אני לא יודעת,
יש המולקה פלישיה,
למה את הצד שלנו? היו
חוזים כאלה
לעניין שאת אומרת שבעצם אמא שלך הלכה עם תחושה של הכעס שלה על בן גוריון,
לא אל בגין.
בין מה אתה מדבר?
לא קונים את זה מאוד. אבל אולי אתם אמרתי זוכר מפה
פויל,
ההורים של פול.
הם
היו
ביתר עם חברים של ז'בוטינסקי ושל בגין,
היחידי בעולם שקרה לפולה פנחס כזה בגיל.
כשאנחנו התחתנו
אני לבשתי מגנים. אמא שלי שפה לאיש חיל האוויר.
אני גם מאוד ברחובות.
אני לא העזתי להגיד לאמא שלי שיש לי בן אדם שהיה בעצם
את לא הזמן
מתחת, אומר גדולה ברחובות, בחצר גדולה
בגיל שבועיים, אומרת זה
לא היה הם. בעצם, מחוצה
בתשובה,
לאבא שלו היה פעיל באחת נשק
כנטל, אלא הוא היה הליכודניקים.
עכשיו
אני
אנחנו שמענו,
פועל
שם תסבוכות,
אבל הוא היה הוא היה ליכוד מקרב
בבחירות של ה.
הוא ניהל את השנייה כפי שהליכוד ביפו,
ואחר כך שהוא נסענו לניו יורק. היה קודם.
זה היה מינוי של משה דיין אמנם, אבל זה יתאים מאוד.
המינויים.
מישהו
בתוך
הליכוד. כן, בטוב שבאדם. זיקים לפלא. בגין השאר שהיה כאן.
דייוויד אני רואה, הייתי רואה את בגין, והם היו אצלנו כל המסחר. מסורת, משפחה. אבל, אבל
אבל
ואני אגיד לך
כש
אבא של פויל,
אמא שלי, התעלמה את החכמה מאוד בעניין הזה.
היום לא היה לה פה אחד, אבל היא לא התרסקה. ב. לא, אף פעם לא אמרה שום דבר על
ז'בוטינסקי. אות.
כשאבא שלי היה בין כבישים,
עשינו פה
מין קבלת פנים, הרמת כוסית
בפואמה, ואמא שלי גרה אצלנו,
מה שהיא נדנדה
כמעט גם את על מינה. וגם עמדה בין כן
אשתו הראשונה, ארץ ישראל
ויקצפו,
ועשינו לו רמת קשים, והזמנו את בגין.
אני רק עם מה שאני ישבה פה על הכיסא.
אולי ניתנה לו יד, התעלמה ממנו,
היה בשבילך,
אבל הוא בא הביתה בגינו ב. לאבא שלי פה
היו חברים. שמו של אביו של פויל, חומסקי,
בן ציון חומסקי. בנציון, גם כן יליד הארץ.
אבל
הוא גורש עם ז'בוטינסקי.
הם היו היום בקריה את
הכור.
לא יודע כמה זמן הם היו, ואחר כך הם
הם קיבלו חנינה.
אם
אין
וגירוש,
אז ההורים של פול
פול נולד פה. גם ים. והוא גדל. צרפת. אבא שלו עבר לצרפת. הוא ידע צרפתית טוב מאוד. אבא שלו
מלמד ב
בשם ג'וזף ביפו,
וזה סיפור
כיפור.
אז
עכשיו אתה יודע הוא
אם יש דין ואהבה. הוא עבר.
עזב את ארץ
התנ. כמה את
מעריכה
הליכודניקים?
כן,
שזיינתי את תיירות למדן, אז היה בתקופה של הבחירות. כאן
זה
הבית, הבן של הרב על פורמט של מרץ. כן, כן,
כן, הבנתי את האמא אומר אני אומר אני לאומית.
כן, הסבתא כן. מה
לדבר
כן,
לא ישנתי.
כן, כן, כן,
אני רואה. ראיתי את רות כמה פעמים,
אמר אך
עליי מאוד מעניין.
אוקיי, אז עכשיו
אני
אלא נאגה. הגענו ל
ל מהוראות.
אני אגיד לך למשל
מתי הספר הלבן
מונית שעד כה
לא היה
בהפגנות עד.
אני חושבת אותי.
אני זוכרת אותי כתלמידת גימנסיה
מפגינה.
אבא שלי עובד בזה.
מה? זה מגיע כל הזמן המשמעותי האחרון פורסם ב
למאי
על זה. אז נפגענו
הגדול, זה היה כן, זה האחרון ששכרו ויציל
את העלייה
את הגולן. כן,
אז עזיבה. אז אני הפגנתי פעולת המין והייתי ב
אני
תראה, הבית היה
הבית שלנו היה וחצי עם לוק סקסוני.
כי
אם העולם צברי תובעני מאוד.
אם יש להם עוד יטען דרזה ככה,
אבל מאוד דומים
אותו מאוד.
ואני כי נשארתי מאוד שומרים. נאמר. הייתי בצופים, הייתי מפילה, הייתי מתעמל, לוט אל על.
וכשהיו בהם ביתה, מאוד בתור, היו באים חברים. ההורים היו מדברים אנגלית. הגנים בישיבה,
אתה יודע איך שזה היה
גם האלה.
כל החברים היקרים שלי היו מתביישים שההורים מדברים.
קורדרו מייפל כחוק, אך לא היה רב. רג,
ככה מתנהלים עד
כן,
ואנחנו כבר נהיה מצברים.
זה זה.
תראה, אני זוכר אותם. מאורעות כן, אני זוכרת עוד משהו
במשפחה שני זה
משפחת קיפניס בתל אביב
הרגו מישהו.
אני
דרך נישואים. אני זוכרת עלינו,
בני דודים שלי. מאני שלי גרוע יותר יש לראות. ורוטשילד
בתחילת
הרגו אותו ביפו
בתחילת המורות של
להיות קטנה ככה
אני חושב שאנחנו שם.
דיברו. אבל אשתי אמרו מילדים
כשלא דיברו על המוות בנוכחות ילדים
היי, אותם
אתם בו?
סליחה,
אין
כשאמרתי סיפרתי לך לראש הפנאי בעוד של
אבא שלי,
כמובן, אני הייתי כבר בוטה
ומגעיל ב ב
ארבע הייתי כבר בתי.
הייתי עסוקה בזה. לא אני
ורק אני אהיה נושא הרבה לקהיר
והם כמה פעמים אנחנו מצטרפות.
ויום אחד הוא אומר לנו
יש ועידה מאוד גדולה של כל אין בעיה
בהודו
והוא מוזמן
ונסה להולי בשבועיים שלח לנו תמונה על ידי טד. שמע,
אחר כך
הוא חזר. אני זוכר את זה כי אנחנו האמא שלי נהגה וישבנו אותו
לטבריה כי
המטוס לנחות על
הים גם את הפול היה טייס כרטיס. כן, כן, כן, כן, כן, כן,
כן. אתם
בחודש
ושמה
היה עניין. כנראה שאבא שלי
מאוד
זה קיבל
והוא שמע את
קול,
המינוס וכל הקבלות,
אתה יודע, וישבו את
ארוחת הערב את של
המשנה למארב. התפקיד הכי חשוב בין מאוד הוא היה וייסבורט
מבחינת מאת אמינות.
הוא שמע, הייתה
פריקים ואתם
יש סידור שולחנות איפה יושבים?
זה היה נוקב,
כבוד מאוד על זה. לא, לא מבוכה, חיטין. אבל מצאתי. מצאתי. הוא שמע. אז לא שמרת פרטים.
ואת זה
זה מאוד.
אז בואו נעשה כך
בואו נסיים
את מה
שצריך.
אם אפשר לקבוע פגישה, תוציא קצת מסמכים ותמונות המשנה,
אני רוצה לצלם. יש לי תיק שלם, אבל הוא בבעלות אומרת
שאל כזה שהוא שם יש מכתבים של אביו
באמת נורא שנמצא לפי זה
נפתח את הסיפור
כל מיני כל מיני מאוד. כי אני רוצה יום אחד גם לשמור את החומר הזה, כי מישהו
אולי כבר מישהו כותב על זה מחקר
על כל הנושא של החלק התעשייה, התרומה של ארץ ישראל התעשייה.
כי יש גם את הסיפור.
קודם כל הנפט,
בתי הזיקוק
זה הדרך, הדברים חדרים חשוב. אז אני אגיד לך
הוא לא כבר לא בחיים.
הבן של סמואל,
הנכד של הנכד של הנציב העליון הראשון. אנו אותו
הדבר.
כן. לא, אני לא מדברת על דיוויד.
אני באמת היה לו אח, דן, שהיה חבר טוב מאוד שלהם,
שעבד בשל פה במה הוא כבר לא בחיים כאשר
אבל בשל
הוא היה גבר
אטרקטיבי כמו שחקן קולנוע וגם מה? היו לו כבר הרבה עירומה רומנים ידועים
ו כשאבריא כי משהו
אחד לא מאוד טוב שלנו היה חבר של אחי, כך
שהבריטים עזבו.
הוא עזב איתם
והוא נעשה. הוא היה בתאילנד, בהם
נהיה מאוד, מאוד מאוד גבוה בשל
אחר כך הוא עבר
לקונטיקו.
אנחנו ייעוד. ראינו בנאדם היו כל ראינו אותו.
אז
הוא יכול היה לספר לך,
אבל הוא כבר ענייננו
זמן יש
ודווין זה הלחימה היא זאת אומרת הפרופסור כן, היינו הולכים היהודי, כן, כן,
אבל
אבל אח שלו, הצעיר דן
וואו,
הוא יעד אם הוא ירד עם הבריטים כך
אבל הוא היה פה.
היה לו תפקיד חשוב. אז לא, אל תביטי בצמחים. בתי זיקוק
בפועל.
אז אז אז אז אז דן. אגב, אז גם
כשאח שלי למד משפטים, לא ארשה. השתמשת של יעקב
סולומון בחיפה
הוא גר. הם
שחררו שלושה והמקים
מוגלים דאדאן. הוא היה
ואחי היה.
אז מה הוא עזב עם הבריטים. ב.
היה קורס, אומר בחיפה. ראיינתי את הבת שלו. היתה מתה עם תמי. לא, משמע
לא חושב. שגרה
לא תאמין, משמע
הוא השיטה בניצב יש בכלא, לא?
לא. כן,
כי הוא היום הפנית את דברי איתי. יעקב שדה, יעקב וייס יש אישור לסולומון עורך דין חיפה?
לא, זה היה ברור שלא רק להגיד לך עוד משהו אחד חשוב
גם
כל הפוספטים בים המלח.
מה זה נובע משתי
קשיש בזמן מלחמת העולם השנייה?
זה היה חלק מתארך גם הברום.
כל הדלק למטוסים.
זה דלק כמו עשב לברום.
וזה הכל הגיע הנייר המלח
עכשיו. כל תעשיית השימורים
המטרות בקיבוצים
זה בלתי נתפס. תחתונים. אני מתה.
אז אבא שלי
הלך. הקיבוצים
אני אומר. אבל אני זוכרת שהוא היה
עם הגרביים. עם תחתונים מדברים. לא, יוג'ין, אפשר גם תחתונים, אני חושבת.
אבל בעיקר אני זוכר גרביים.
התחילו עד לשוד. גרביים. חכי. גדולות כאלה בצבא?
כן,
יש איזה שיפור.
אבל זה את
אומרת אנשים.
מי שעוסק בהיסטוריה מודע
ש התנופה
לתעשייה
התחילה ב
או הרבה
כן
בזה, או אלא להאמין בעצם, בזמנו לבין
כשהצבאות היינו שם
להיות סבא.
אנחנו סיפקנו להם המון דברים. מאוד
אפשר.
קשה,
קשה להגיד המילה, אבל
בזמן השואה הפרוספיריטי
זה קשה להגיד את זה,
היה עד
היום.
כן, היה תפקיד מאוד.
ופה המשחק. העניין הזה עם האמביוולנטיות.
אמא ממערכת יחסים הבריטים. אני אף פעם לא מאשים את הבריטים,
בטח לא
לא ממניע
אנטישמי
מה שקורה בעצם. מסתכלים על זה בתמונה הגדולה
שמתכוון מלחמת העולם השנייה. קולו עניינית, אם לומר
לא, אבל שמסתכלים עליו מפה עולמית.
יש
אז
מיליון
ערבים
מוסלמים
שיושבים בנמלים. היה הנפט של עיראק היה אחד הדברים הכי חשובים לו פרש'
הקודם היה לראות. לא, קודם היה פרס אחד, אבל אחר כך היא רק היום, כי היה השיפורים מוצדק.
וכל כל הנושא הזה של לשמור על שקט
לאורך החופים של המזרח התיכון
מרוקו,
מצרים,
לוב, זה הכל מוסלמים.
להיכנס למלחמת העולם השנייה
בלי תמיכה של העולם המוסלמי,
לעומת
שש מאות אלף. היא
לא פה ששמו אתה מדבר על כל ה
מיליון. אוקיי,
כל זה
זה המחיר ששילמנו.
תראה,
אי אפשר להאשים את הבריטים בשורה.
אפשר להאשים אותם בזה שהם לא פתחו את השערים לא
לא באנגליה ולא בארצות הברית, וגם לא בישראל, וגם האמריקאים
היו נוראיים.
לא נתנו. יש
אנשים שעברו, אני קוראת הרבה מאוד עולות על ההתקפה הזו.
צ'אבו לבקשת את
האישום כאישה לארצות הברית, ולא
דומה
למה
אנחנו לא זהו
מי
לא,
גברתי.
סטטיסטיקה
הספר
אשר טבעי כקרן אמרו כבר
גמרו את אלה. מעולם לא גמרו את אלה מבלגיה, וזה
לא
נורא. אמריקאים היו
נגדם
לפני חצי שנה,
ובמקום שבו נמצא סנט לואיס
בסנט לואיס יצא
ב
למאי.
זאת הייתה חלק מ. אפרופו גנדה של ריברס,
הוא רצה להראות
בבקשה.
הם גם פחדו מהם, מהווה
הישג אל
המחר.
החרם הגרמנים מאוד דייגו על החרם שגם היהודים הכריזו עליו בארצות הברית
זה ישפיע על הכלכלה.
ממש.
הסיפור אחר מתחיל
בפעולה
הזאת.
כי בעצם
אבל לא זו
היה
היישוב היהודי. היה בעד. אוקיי, זה הדיל.
אנחנו משאירים את הכסף פה
ולוקחים סחורה
וציוד נחלנו אז היום הליכוד.
הליכוד משמיט שתיאר את השידור הזה,
כי אפשר לחשוב אם גם כן לא, אבל מצד אפשר,
אם מסתייגים להיכנס לראש שלהם, הסיפור הוא כזה
משהו. ז'בוטינסקי אמר אז
ושעם כל סוחרי העולם היהודים
עם ההשפעה שלהם
הכריזו על חרם על גרמניה ויפעלו בכל מדינה שיש להם את הכוח.
אני רק
עד ארצות הברית,
אז יכול להיות שתהיה השפעה,
כי הגרמנים היו צריכים כסף לבנות את המהלך השלישי בהרבה מאוד כסף יהודי
בנה את הרייך השלישי.
חלק מהעניין. אבל מצד שני זה הביא לפה את כל תעשיית
לוויניים,
הנגרות,
המכניקה ציז. למה הבחורה הוא הגיע?
חלק מהעניין הוא עד לא היה פליט
אם איזה אלה שהגיעו בין שלושה
הגיעו שישים אלף ין יקים.
כן, נדמה לי בשנים האלה מ
מ
כן,
אני אומר לך המון. אני זוכרת את זה בירושלים
דיסקים, וככה הגיע לבית. היא מטפסת על לפני כניסת לקוראת את האשמה. לא תממש ממנה.
בן יהודה שרף זה
אני מעיף את זה בדיוק את זה.
אבל אני זוכרת את דם ירושלים, כי בירושלים הגיעו.
אני אומר לך בלומנפלד פגיעים, וכל
כל משפחות
משפחות כאלה כביכול אינטלקטואליות הפרופסורים. והם גם קיבלו ג'ובים באוניברסיטה.
חלק מהם,
כל רכבי, הייתה מלאה.
וכל הרופאים
הרופאים שאנחנו גנבנו בירושלים
חצי עוף, והם היו איתי
גם
כן. אפשר.
אם את רוצה לחבר את זה רק אם אין להם
השפעה,
בואו ניכנס לראש של הערבים.
מה הם רואים בשנות השלושים?
זרם
של יהודים. וזה בונים מדינה פורחת. וזה מה שמביא את מאורעות בעצם.
נכון.
אז הכל פה מתקשר
שוב הבריטים. לנהל אמפר זה קשה.
טוב
לסיים להיום?
כן. אני לא אני,
אני
אני. אני שואלת אם אתה
צריך להגיע גם אליי לא שבעצם מעניין איך למלא את השיפוע. בוא נעשה עוד פגישה.
כן,
כן, אפשר ללכת היום.
אני
את
המועדונים של קורבנות שמקיימים לנו משהו טוב בגיל תשעה חודשים. להביא? כן,
אבל
תראה עם מי מעומד. הוא סרטן, לא היה כימאי במכון ויצמן.
חיי
זה כל החבר'ה שהברים הפולימרים
במחקרים בשנות השישים, אמר איך קוראים לכם
פלג לזה?
המחלקה של היום. קציר.
רגע, מי אני?
שמות של דבר נורא.
רינה קשר
לשאר
היה מדען
במכון ויצמן שגם באמת שאני מעורר קנאה. איש מוכשר מאוד. אני. היא הייתה איתי ב
למאי.
אני יודעת.
הבן שלו חושב שאלן מאוד מוצלח ב שבי פשע.
אוקיי,
אבל אני יודעת שהוא מת.
היה גן בגלל הכל אחרי
התקופה עם החומרים וגם איך שחיים עם זה. אז אבא שלך
היה אחד מהם? אני הייתי אז בן תשעה חודשים.
אז אתה בן כמה בן כמה הוא היה?
ארבעים.
אני אתן בסכומים.
אז העניין הזה של האלמנה עם שלושה ילדים. אני הייתי השלישי.
אני גדלתי בסטטוס הזה של העונה עם שלושה ילדים
לבירת ישראל. העניין הזה של
אלמנה לא של מלחמה זה דרג יותר נמוך.
זה קצת יותר קשה,
אבל תמיד
וגם קריית איתרו
וקרא לה. כמה פעמים שאני מדבר על קריירות יש לדברים. ההיכרות הייתה מאוד שירה
כן, במצבם הכלכלי שהיה קשה היה קשה, כנראה
היא שוכבת. היא שוכבת,
כן.
אז תראי אצלנו
אני
כן.
קודם כל, אמא שלי היתה כנראה אישה חזקה, חזקה מאוד, על
הטרגדיה של אבא שלי. זה הזהרת, כי זה שינה את כל החיים. היא גם עשתה החלטות כל כך לא נכונות.
היה לנו בית גדול בירושלים,
המשפחה הייתה מאוד מקובלת,
אורחים ומארחים, וקונצרטים
כזה מין
בית מאוד פתוח. וזה
וכשאמא שלי מהרג היא אמרה אני לא חוזרת. הבית
בחזרה לרחובות,
איפה שהיא גדלה
הביתה. מספיק ארוך כזה והיה לו שם הפינה,
אבל כבר
יש את חוכ,
הייתה בת חמישים ומשהו, יושב חוג חברים חדשים ביניהם,
ואחר כך תוך
היא ישנה אחת, אך לא נולדה,
אז היה לה
אין לי ציפיות כאלה. עישנת את
בגין, כמובן,
שנא את
בן גוריון.
לא אמרת גם באופי שלו, גם
גם כשלפני שקרא לה עם הקינדל
לעבוד.
אבל
אני חושבת שאנחנו גדלנו בתקופה.
אם עשית כל
כך
מרגשת
של מילוש,
אנחנו לא שאלנו את עצמנו באמצע אני אומר אני אומרת את זה לא בכל הצניעות
אני
עם
כן, אבל הסתכלנו קדימה גם
שאחי נהרג בידי. זה היה מעין בעיה
שאהבה
נפשי, אך
זה היה נורא.
אבל
איך שכל הזמן
היתה השנייה
אז לא.
ואחר כך אני קוראת שיש
ארגון הקורבנות
זה הכל גם קשת פיצויים שהקורבנות שלי
שזה ופרו בעולם שזה
זה מזעזע אותי עכשיו אנשים מצטלמים בטלוויזיה
עוד לפני הקבורה נכון?
נורא,
נורא
וזה נוזל אותי
מביאים את האלה לא עושים לו אותי אבל זה פשוט יחסי ציבור
כן
תודה
אני לא
בעניין זה אבל אנשים השתנו תראה הכל עליך כעת
מספרים לך הכל בטלוויזיה היום
אבל כשאני רואה
קורבנות
אנשים
שאיבדו ילדים או לא, או חיילים או כל מיני
ותקווה טלוויזיה שם הם כולם מתראיינים
מה זה
אבל זה נכון שאנחנו אני אני לא מת אנחנו חיים בתקופה מאוד טובה
עם כל כך הרבה כוויות
היום אנחנו מדוע
מדוכאים על מוות אבל זה
כמו שחוששים בוא נעשה ככה כי
אני גם הולכת לישון האירוע בירושלים
ביום שאני
משתתף בו
ונס